[Music]
my name is Madhuri and Emani I'm a
product manager and the gke team I focus
mostly on some of the multi-tenancy
aspects of kubernetes i'm joined by my
colleague jung hwan a software engineer
at Google and David Shaw an
infrastructure engineer at Spotify as
kids we have all been taught that
sharing is good
whether you're sharing an apartment a
meal a ride-sharing indeed has a number
of benefits you can save time money and
resources but I would add a small caveat
sharing is a great thing as long as you
share everything fairly otherwise things
can turn sour I'm sure most of you at
some point would have faced something
similar
sharing a GAE cluster is no different
you need good visibility into which
tenant is consuming what portion of the
cluster resources because again you it's
very important to be fair to all the
tenants so this session is all about how
you can effectively share a multi-tenant
GK cluster while holding each tenant
accountable for their usage so let's
look at the agenda for today we'll start
with the benefits of multi tenant
clusters and why we need fine-grained
visibility into usage will then look at
the overview of GK usage metering
feature and the underlying architecture
I'm very excited that we have David with
us today David will demo how Spotify
uses GAE and how the feature helps solve
some of the pain points of large multi
tenant GK clusters will end the session
with key takeaways and best practices
before opening the floor for questions
talking about questions if you have any
questions about this session we invite
you to use Dory Q&A Dory is an app we
use internally at
to handle Q&A to use story go to the
next app click on this session and then
click on the Dory Q&A link once you
click the link you will be able to add a
question and you will be able to upload
or download any questions you want to
hear answered so there's a number of
advantages of using multi-tenant
clusters to understand the benefits
let's actually step back and think about
what happens when you have separate
cluster for each tenant first for each
additional cluster you will have
additional control plane overhead and
management burden second in a large
system where perhaps you have hundreds
or even thousands of namespaces or
hundreds or thousands of different
tenants you need tools to manage those
many clusters at scale even with very
good tooling it can be hard to manage
those many clusters more importantly
when the free or idle resources of each
cluster cannot be reused by other
tenants applications on the contrary if
you use multi tenant clusters then
obviously you have lower control plane
overhead and better resource utilization
and also you'll have less resource
fragmentation to illustrate with an
example let's say you have one team
which is focusing on real-time
applications which are presumably more
active during the day and you have
another team that is focusing on batch
applications which can be run during the
night sharing the resources for the two
teams can provide significant savings
coupon IDs can optimize resource usage
by efficiently bin packing applications
from different tenants also it's much
faster to provision resources for a
tenant within an existing cluster than
to bootstrap a cluster from the scratch
last but not the least all the tenants
of a multi-tenant GK cluster can share
any sort of extension
see IDs or controllers and also because
they are sharing the same control plane
any sort of configuration settings
reliability measures security measures
are automatically shared by all the
tenants so if there's lot of benefits
what's the problem
fine-grained visibility into resource
usage becomes very important in
multi-tenant environments because in the
absence of fine-grained metrics it can
be hard to estimate which tenant is
consuming what portion of the clusters
resources it can be tough to determine
which tenant has perhaps introduced a
bug that led to a sudden spike in
resource usage or it can be hard to
identify the political tenants who
perhaps themselves they don't know that
they're wasting resources let's actually
look a little bit deeper to understand
who exactly needs fine-grained
visibility and why they need it if you
look at finance and procurement
professionals they need to understand
actual resource usage numbers because
they need to have a concrete basis for
staff for estimating chargebacks if you
don't have the real usage numbers and
you resort to ballpark estimates or
rough heuristics it can again be unfair
to some of the tenants also as a finance
officer you want to make sure that the
cost versus benefit is justified for
different initiatives within your
organization you want to make sure that
you are able to provide good forecasts
for planning and budgeting purposes all
of which again require a good
understanding of usage patterns and the
historical trends if you are a site
reliability engineer asari or a cluster
administrator it is very important to
catch any sort of configuration errors
or bugs that can lead to spikes in
usages a simplest example could be that
one of your teams has accidentally
forgotten to wind down after running at
or after running updates for several
applications you might realize that
suddenly the inter region network
traffic which is the expensive kind of
traffic has suddenly become 20 times the
original amount in those scenarios you
want to be able to drill down and catch
the source of the problem as quickly as
possible on similar lines if you are an
IT director or a product manager you
want to make sure that the fundamental
business aspects of your product or
application are making sense for example
is the revenue generated by your product
more than the is more than the cost of
building the product and operating it
are your team's expenses within the
allocated budget are you well planned
for the future I mean for example if you
anticipate that your users for your
project product are going to become 20
times within the next year you want to
have a good sense of how many resources
you have to reserve to sustain that
growth and overall in most of the cases
providing a dashboard or report to each
engineering team where the teams can
look for themselves the usage trends for
their applications that in itself can
provide significant savings because
ultimately nobody wants to waste
resources so there's several use cases
of fine grained metrics and GK usage
metering feature is the solution to
those use cases the feature allows you
to see the plot your projects resource
usage broken down by Kuban et's
namespaces and labels and attribute it
into meaningful entities the fine
grained metrics are captured at pod
level the user can then filter group and
aggregate the fine grained metrics to
calculate usage for different entities
the entity can be a department an
environment a team and application
whatever makes sense
to you looking into the key aspects of
the feature we are currently at beta
usage can be segregated based on both
cuban IDs namespaces and labels and the
combination gives a lot of flexibility
to the users whether you want to look at
a micro level and understand which sub
component of your application is taking
up most of your resources all you want
to look at a macro level and understand
the usage for the whole department or
team or you just want to estimate the
cost of running a load test you can
arrive at all those numbers using the
feature provided you use labels and
namespaces to organize your workloads
and the last part is really important
for the benefit of those of you who are
not familiar with Cuba net his
namespaces and labels let me take a
quick detour detour namespaces provide a
mechanism to split Cuba Nettie's objects
into separate non overlapping groups
labels on the other hand are arbitrary
key value pairs that you can attach to
any of your Cuban IDs objects to
illustrate with an example let's say if
you have a company which has ten
different departments and let's say each
department on average has 15 different
microservices
then one way to organize your workloads
would be to have ten namespaces one for
each department and for each of your
micro service you can attach identifying
attributes such as application name sub
component name you can attach the tier
name tier being the front-end or
back-end or whatever makes sense for you
or you can even attack attach the
release or version IDs the key is to
make sure you organize your workloads in
a way that is meaningful to you if
everything gets deployed into the
default namespace and you don't use any
labels then you'll not be able to take
advantage of the full potential of the
feature so back to the features in terms
of resource types we are currently
supporting
CPU memory PD GPUs and Network egress
@ga will provide support for even TPU
and custom machine types in terms of
reported metrics we are currently
supporting request based metrics yang
will talk more about the metrics a
little bit later but at GA we will
support even consumption based metrics
with that I turn it over to yang for a
high-level architecture overview yeah
thank you Madhu
I'd like to start with the talking about
how resource usage is measured in GAE in
this picture the three parts represents
the G key master VM which is a
controller of a kubernetes cluster and
the yellow boxes represents notes in
your class sure to measure resource
usage in a GT cluster we have developed
this usage metric agent which also runs
on the G key master VM so it's totally
managed by Google and you don't need to
worry about deploying it and the keeping
it up and running to measure a paused
CPU and memory usage the metering agent
talks to the QB cube API server and
collects information such as the
starting and ending time of a part
how many CPUs and memories are being
requested by the pod as well as the pods
namespace and the labels you know very
similar fashion resource usage of
storage or even GPUs can be recorded but
not all information is available from
the Cuba API server and one of the
missing piece is networker statistic you
might be wondering why do I need to know
that well the network statistics gives
you insight into the behavior of your
application for example if you see a
sudden spike in traffic Center - in an
unknown region the might indicate there
is a bug or even worse there is your
application is under attack what are the
more sending traffic to certain region
is not your free
so you want to collect Network
statistics so that when you perform cost
allocation you can allocate the network
us to talents that are generate the
traffic to solve this problem we also
developed this naturally monitoring
component that is deployed into a giclee
cluster as a daemon set so there's a
one-component running on each node in
your cluster the component that talks to
the system kernel to grab draw network
statistics and send the statistic to the
centralized a metering agent the
metering agent to process the statistic
and the converted to using a record and
send the record to bigquery together
with the records for other resources
such as CPU and memory once the usage
record are available in bigquery you can
now perform various analysis such as
getting the aggregate user CPU usage of
forgiven namespace or calculate the
total memory bytes being requested by
the application but a more interesting
use case would be to use the usage data
and join up with the GCP billing data to
do cost reallocation on one hand from
chica user data
you know how much resource is being used
by a team on an application and on the
other hand GCP billing data tells you
how much you are paying for a piece of
or cloud of results in GCP joining them
together allows you to understand how
much a team on an application is
actually costing you even though it's
running on a shared computer
infrastructure and once you perform the
cost of breakdown you can even export
data in bigquery to external tools such
as the data studio for visualization and
we actually provides you with the data
studio template to make the process
easier for you before we move on I like
to talk briefly about why we choose to
collect a resource request as you might
have already know there are three
metrics related in the coronary resource
model the resource request
represents the amount of requests being
the amount of results being requested or
reserved for a part and the consumption
represents the actual amount of results
being used at a wrong time by a part and
the lastly resource limit poses an upper
bound on the resource consumption among
these three metrics missing we choose to
measure resource requests and use it for
costly allocation because we believe is
more relevant to the cost of your
cluster and let me explain why so first
of all when Cube schedulers schedule
paws each uses the powder is requested
to see whether the part can be fit on a
note and once the part is assigned to a
note the scheduler sinks considers the
amount of will request the resource
being reserved for that particular part
regardless whether party is actually
using it cubes scheduler we are stopped
assigned more party to a note if the
know that are not helpful enough on
request rate or unreserved capacity and
if none of the note in your cluster has
enough unreserved capacity pausing your
unassigned pauses in your system becomes
pending and that is the ones the cluster
autoscaler start you that you resize
your cluster by adding more notes into
your cluster and this is the one the
cost of your classic goes up so based on
these reasons we believe resource
request is more it's more relevant to
the culture of your clutter and decided
to use requester to allocate the overall
cost of your cluster and with that I
would like to pass a flaw to David to
talk about how gpu-z geometry could be
used in Spotify I just think that
everyone thanks young for that great
explanation my name is David I work at
Spotify as an infrastructure engineer my
team specifically works on migrating
Spotify stateless back-end services from
GCE right now to
uke and I'm actually glad to be here
today to show you how this new gk
feature that they've built looks and
feels first a little bit about Spotify
and our the scale of our GCP usage so we
have over a thousand developers we have
created that that number is correct 2800
GCP projects all under one org that's a
lot of projects and spread out across
all of those projects are tens of
thousands of GCE instances so that's
kind of the scale that we're running at
and how do we use GCP how to restructure
our usage teams will own at least one
project there's usually one we tell
people to create one project per logical
system and teams own their GC instances
when did their projects they are
responsible for provisioning that
capacity for deploying services on to
them and monitoring them so they truly
own it in every sense the centralized
like infrastructure teams don't don't
really do that we provide tools for them
and you get cost breakdown for free in
your GCP billing invoice by project so
that's kind of just easy there
the lack of multi-tenancy though adds
operational burden on teams so what I
kind of just described in the in the
first three bullets is how the vast
majority of Spotify back-end services
are structured on GCP and as you can
probably tell it's a single tenant
design so people just like run their
service on one machine and if they need
multiple replicas they just get more
instances so it's very very poor
resource utilization and it puts a lot
of operational burden on them because
they need to know how many instances
they need what machine types they need
to manage all that themselves and we're
trying to migrate to gke because it
reduces this operational burden by
abstracting away these instances and
also it makes it easier for for us
on the infrastructure side to increase
that resource consumption efficiency
yeah so how do we plan on using GK there
are many we have many production gke
clusters we put them all in one project
the team that I work on owns these multi
tenant clusters and we similar to two
GCP projects we tell people to create
one kubernetes namespace per logical
system not per team it makes it easier
because people inevitably transfer
systems from one team to another they
maybe split something out and it's just
easier if it's already in it's no
namespace and if we want to label things
let's say we have like common service
across namespaces we'll just apply the
same label there so that you can later
kind of query for the same workload
across multiple namespaces so we use
labels in that way and same way with
projects that team can own many
namespaces and how do we do the
ownership mapping how do we tell which
namespaces oh and by which team we use
we require actually a an annotation so
when a team creates the namespace CMO we
require they have a specific annotation
that is called the owner annotation and
then we do validation and linting before
we allow them to merge it in and that
that value must be a an engineering
teams email and we do some validation to
make sure it's actually a real team
that's been able to use GK and there's
no typos or anything like that so
namespace yeah namespace ownership can
change it's done very easily just by
changing the value of that annotation we
also require loose resource quotas for
all namespaces this is done very easily
you can just enable it in your admission
controller and right now we're just only
migrating stateless back in services for
now we're not doing anything saiful so
when I show you the demo later that's
why you'll only see CPU and memory you
won't see anything like persistent disks
and just a little bit about our
migration challenges and this cup this
is where the the feature comes into play
so when you're using GCP you get billing
reports that are broken down by project
very simple and our finance team uses
those invoices to kind of get insight
into which team is using resources what
kind of resources they use it to project
our how our costs are going to grow over
time so what's happening now you can
probably can already tell that when we
migrate to GK and all these clusters are
multi-tenant they're used by many teams
and they're all in one project the
billing reports are gonna look a little
bit funky right what's gonna happen is
my team's project costs are gonna go up
as people migrate and those other teams
projects costs are gonna go down because
they're moving their computer way
they're kind of getting rid of it and it
looks to finance like why is this team
using so much compute like what was
going on are they just being wasteful
are they running something insane but
that's it's actually kind of hidden
what's happening is that we're subsuming
other teams costs so migrating to gk
without any fine-grained cost breakdown
would means we can't tell how many
resources each team is consuming which
system is suddenly using more resources
maybe it's due to a bug which systems
are being wasteful in their resource
requests but luckily gk usage metering
helps us solve these problems and how do
we plan on using gk usage metering so
like I said our finance team will gain
insight into the cost breakdown they can
forecast future costs they can analyze
the seasonality of different systems
individual teams can also see their own
costs we want them to see their own
costs so that they're aware and my team
or other central teams that provide
tools can identify candidate systems for
cost reductions let's say we noticed
you're requesting I don't like eight
CPUs for each of your pods but they only
really need to use one even you know at
peak load so we can investigate these
pod resource requests for anomalies or
unreasonable values we can even try to
look at maybe this service that's not
that doesn't need to be running all the
time or is not critical it can be we can
schedule it onto some preemptable nodes
and save some money there so I think
that brings me to the demo so let me
just come over here okay
so here is the demo Oh actually first I
want to show you how you even get to
this it's one second so it's let me show
you on the terminal how do you enable
this feature first you need an existing
gke cluster I've already got that done
next you need a data set somewhere in
bigquery because all of this when you
enable it all this data is going to get
exported to a bigquery data set so here
we go I've run this before I'll just go
over this command a little bit to use
g-cloud you say which project that you
want I have the beta flag here container
clusters and it's an update command you
give it the name of the cluster so I
have a testing cluster here in Europe
that region is also Europe and you then
give it the the bigquery data set that's
kind of the target where all the data is
going to go to so I have a test data set
here and let that run for a little bit
we'll update the cluster it'll come back
and say done it's done and then just to
verify that it is actually enabled for
this cluster you can run this other
command so I use fish actually I'm
curious how many people use fish shell
out there this is a completely random
question yes cool the actual fun fact
the original author of fish currently
works the Spotify
so it's great tool that he provided
anyways so here's how you check that
your cluster actually has it enabled you
run this you tell it to describe a
cluster the same cluster I had before
and you just give a little format string
you say I want to see the value of
resource usage export config and if you
did it right you should get some some
kind of output back and the output says
here's the data set ID that I'm gonna
send your data to okay so we're all good
let me show you what that dataset looks
like so here's my bigquery data set and
I have a project here called warp-speed
Rd that's the name of my team and here's
the here's that's the project here's the
data set
usage metering demo and I have - this is
the this one usage metering this is the
the table that's going to get created
from when you enable that feature and
this other table here is a copy of just
your your your billing export from your
GCP billing data and you need this to
know how you're gonna join these two
tables later and you need this other one
to know like how much did things cost so
here let me run a sample query for you
this queries a bit long so bear with me
but I'm gonna kind of explain it very
briefly what it does actually mean let
me show you a preview of the table first
so this table is it's got a bunch of
columns it gives you a cluster location
it gives you the cluster name the
namespace kind of things you'd expect
right the resource type start time end
time fraction but it doesn't give you
cost here it just gives you the usage
your mouth so you have to join it to get
the cost so this is where this query
gives you a good example of that it
selects a bunch of columns and here we
are going to get actually some some
labels out of the different namespaces
and I'm selecting the
data out of the gk usage metering table
which is the feature what the feature
provides I'm gonna join it with my
billing table so here's the billing
export table let me know if people can't
see in the back I hope you can see this
and then I'm just gonna limit it to the
first week of March to make it fast and
there's a bunch of group eyes or I
grouped by the cluster name the cluster
location I order by costs descending so
I'm gonna go with this so actually all
of this all of this data is actually
just for illustrative purposes only it's
not it's not actually real data it's
kind of just fake made-up but we'll let
that run and it's done and here's what
some of that looks like so first row we
see this as production Asia East one
that's the name of the cluster it's in
surprise Asia East one region
I like renewable energy so I kind of
just made up all these name sweets names
so we got hydroelectric here and this
name space uses this amount of memory
here from you know February 1st through
March 7th it costs I'm pretty sure this
is US dollars so this cost over a
thousand dollars doesn't have any labels
so this is an example of what that data
looks like but it's a lot today just you
probably don't want to like look at this
raw because it's it's a lot unless you
want to like specifically check out
certain things and make sure your data
is sane and correct and what you expect
but luckily in the documentation for
usage renewing they give you these great
data studio templates which you can just
copy and plug into this data set and
then you can have these very nice
beautiful visualizations which look like
this so the the provided for out of the
box template just has these three pages
I'm gonna walk you through each of these
three there's a little date drop down
here I'm showing you the first month of
or the month of February through the
first week of March and again all of
this data as you can tell is all made up
so it's all again fake with made-up
namespaces over here we got a little pie
chart of
the cost breakdown by namespace so we
can see that 42% is it's just others
namespaces but the biggest one is this
one called wind photovoltaics comes in
second so you can see very quickly who's
using the most this table over here is
the same thing but just in a tabular
format and you can get a break down over
here by the resource type so again
because we're using stateless services
only there's only CPU and memory and
here we got a cost trends by namespace
over time as you can see for some reason
photovoltaics is going way down but wind
is going up for some reason and on the
next page you can see more cost trends
maybe you want to drill down by name
space over time maybe you just want to
focus on one cluster maybe you just want
to see okay in this cluster in the
production Europe cluster only and I
want to see just photovoltaics how much
that change over time oh maybe there's
something interesting about this data
like there was a spike in the middle of
February and our finance team can go
drilled in drill down into that and see
what happened there and the last blast
page is similar it's over time but in
this one you can slice and dice by
labels it's kind of the same thing here
cluster resource name and then you have
the label key and then the label value
that you can select that's it for the
demo let me go back to the slides thanks
thank you alright so how does this
experience compare with and without
resource usage metering it's like what
are you what are you actually getting by
using this feature you don't need to do
all the manual collection of the data
yourself they did some great magic I
don't know how it works but it does and
I trust it to work and that saves me a
lot of time right the bigquery sync
makes it super easy to run ad-hoc
queries in BigTable so or bigquery you
can just write sequel you can
kind of run some ad hoc queries you can
schedule jobs if you want them to recur
the docs are great there's you can just
like walk through them in a very short
amount of time and it's pretty
self-explanatory and the templated data
studio visualizations are great you you
can also plug in your own visualization
if you want and maybe you have another
tool that you prefer anything that
connects to to bigquery welcome to use
that and the GK usage metering can be
used to check other metering tools
accuracy maybe you have like another
tool that also collects data and kind of
does the same thing but you want to
check that accuracy maybe you want to
check each other just another possible
use case cool so with that I'm going to
give it back for back to young to talk
about best practices Thanks
[Applause]
thank you David this is a excellent demo
so to quickly follow up as a
demonstrated GE uses your metering
provides you with fine-grained
visibility into the resource usage in
your cluster so I want to quickly talk
about how you can get the most out of
what GK use your metering in practice as
soon we provide we allows you to group
usage by kubernetes name spaces and
labels so its idea for you to
standardize and then enforce a namespace
and labeling strategy within your
organization first of all it's a highly
recommended for you to use namespace as
a boundaries for either system or teams
in particular do not put everything into
the default namespace this not only
helps you to understand this usage but
also makes it easier for you to manager
coder and the policy in your cluster
secondly it is recommended for you to
define a set of would require labels so
that you can associate your essential
attribute with kubernetes objects such
as the application IDs or team names
overall the namespace and labeling
strategy you choose should reflect
reflect your organizational structure so
that you can easily map a resource usage
to for example a team within your
company or a business unit so we have
talked about how GE use the geometry can
do right now what is next we are looking
forward to launching the feature
incubator in this culture and in beta we
will be supporting consumption based on
metrics together with the existing
requests based on metrics so this wheel
allows you to identify area where
resources are either over requested or
on the requested we hope it can help you
to better optimize the resource usage of
your chicken cluster we will also be
supporting more computer resources
namely the tensor flow processing units
as well as a GCE
instance with
bushing types so this brings me to the
end of the presentation to quickly wrap
up we talked about there are numerous
advantages to operate multi-tenant at GE
cluster namely H makes the cluster
management easier and also improve the
resource utilization we understand in a
multi-tenant GE cluster getting insight
into resource usage particular pertinent
resource usage is important and the
cheeki usage metering is designed to
solve this problem each generator uses
your record and exported to be queried
together with the associated namespace
and labels allows you to flexibly
grouping and filtering usage and also we
provide you can export the data from
bigquery to data to you for
visualization and we provide a default
data to the template to make the process
easier for you if you want to know more
about a gpu-z metering we have links to
our blog post and the documentation if
you want you let us know the feedback
about this feature we also have a link
to the feedback form here with that
thank you very much for your time
[Music]